something's happening to us
we need to find the others we haven't
seen some of them for centuries
you hear that Sprite family reunion it's
about time
it's a really interesting mix having 10
characters we're a big slightly
dysfunctional family this is what the
end of the world looks like at least we
have front row seats well you know
what's never saved the planet you're
sarcasm
Cersei she has the power to manipulate
matter and she's had a long running on
off relationship with Icarus how long
were you together five thousand years I
guess you can call that long term
Icarus is the loyal Soldier yeah that's
Superman with the cape and you're
shooting
late I don't wear a cape
pastors can assemble anything out of any
kind of Technology there were more
deviants than you said well I'm sure
that was fun for you it was
Athena she's the goddess of war she can
manifest different weapons
which was very fun
Gilgamesh he's a protector his specialty
is a strong punch
this is Makari none of us have seen it
for centuries
Sprite can
she's really sarcastic especially with
Kingo
I would say Kingo if
a little self-involved can go didn't we
start I've directed some things too
droog he's mind control he stands up for
what he believes and that there
shouldn't be violence don't we don't
interfere in their Wars and then there
is Ajax she's kind of the leader of the
eternals her power is healing this
planet and these people have changed me
these superheroes reflect the world we
live in everybody is unique and special
I think it Charles is the most epic
movie that Marvel has done and I really
really mean that
they're really gonna see a movie unlike
any they've ever seen before
[Music]
right
[Music]
thank you
Icarus
evening ladies
[Music]
who is it
[Music]
sorry